Here's a picture of the teapot with the lid off. You can see the inside of the
teapot. What's odd here is that the outside and inside surfaces have the same
lighting. This is because the same normals are used to calculate both the inside
and outside surfaces. That is, all the normals point outwards. Regardless of
whether we're looking at the inside or outside. This is certainly not how the
real world works. I call this the paper lantern effect, where the surface is
sort of like a paper lantern, looking the same on both sides. However, if you
think about it, the shading here is really not like anything in the real world.
For example, if we put a light inside this lantern all of the surfaces would be
dark. This is because they're normals all point away from the light. Say we want
to fix this problem and have the surface be double-sided? Which of the following
fixes will work? First if the normal is facing away from the light, don't render
diffuse and specular, render the model twice. Once with backface culling on.
Once with frontface culling on and flipping each shade normal direction. Make
and also render a second set of triangles in the same locations, but with their
normals reversed. Do not cull. Put a second light opposite the first light,
pointing in the opposite direction.